teams from the RAF worked to stem the
flow of water into the town of Waynflete
three Chinook helicopters dropping bags
of gravel to plug the burst banks of the
river steeping but the water has already
flooded more than a hundred homes here
residents evacuated after more than two
months of rain fell in just two days
Paul Reville helped move his elderly
neighbors to safety last night we met
him just as he and his wife returned to
find their favourite flooded so you've
only just finished decorating yeah
last week and it's contaminated water as
well so you can't even dry it up there's
a pond there but we just thought we'd
landscape the garden little returning
proves the water feature was really
going back inside was the real shock I
think really it started to hit home I
thought we'd got away with it to be
honest and it's not good local farmers
and volunteers worked through the night
to help evacuate residents and they're
back again today shoring up weak points
with more sandbags
we've been out and about since about
office for this morning I went over and
cooked I was sleeping up a cow again
dozens of firefighters from four
counties a helping Lincolnshire after a
state of emergency was declared the
number of flood warnings remain in place
the water was you know the big problem
how fast it was coming into the village
as well so as fast as we were able to
put it somewhere else it was just
continuing in back 4 or so it was a real
struggle residents on the other side of
the town have already lost power supply
so the priority for the fire service
here is to protect this electricity
supply because it's not just powering
more than a hundred homes here it's also
powering the pumps that are pumping away
this flood water
the weather is due to improved through
the weekend but it could be months
before many here can return home
Sally Lockwood Sky News East
Lincolnshire